David carrick's crimes were unspeakably
evil
the treatments that he subjected his
victims and the survivors too was truly
truly degrading and he inhumane
their courage has been extraordinary and
coming forward and
helping today him be brought to Justice
their courage is admirable
but we we in policing have failed
uh he should not have been a police
officer
there were many signs that we should
have joined together
he should have been rooted out during
his career as a police officer
It's upsetting to be stood here talking
about this
um and I apologize again to the victims
and indeed I apologize to the women of
London many of whom I'm sure will be
troubled and their trust in policing
will be shaken by shaken by these events
we recognize as police officers
that we have a big task ahead if we're
to regain that trust
I have tens of thousands of colleagues
men and women who really care about
policing London and recognize the scale
of that challenge and what needs to be
done
I've been really clear from day one as
commissioner four months ago that one of
the challenges for me was to root out
those that corrupt the Integrity in the
metropolitan police
and this case and others like it
illustrate that challenge
today is not a day for going through
action plans
um
today is a day for reflection and
apologizing to victims
but I have been very clear we will
update at the end of March with the
progress that we've made
as we go step by step to tackle these
issues and remove those that shouldn't
be shouldn't be serving as police
officers
we won't resolve this overnight but as
we lift the stones and deal with what's
underneath it you will see progress
month by month quarter by quarter
I finished where I started I apologize
to the women of London I repeat my
admiration for the women who came
forward and I promised the people of
London we will do better and we'll give
you the Police Service you deserve
if I think it's just gonna take two or
three questions you've spoken about
trying to get the Integrity back of the
met but after harboring this monster in
your midst for so long aren't you
worried that women are never going to
trust the Met again
people are going to be very shaken by
this I I completely recognize that
we are determined to tackle this most of
our people are great people but we've
been too weak at getting rid of the ones
who aren't
so you're going to see month by month
changes as we remove those individuals
and you can report on that I know my
words today aren't enough
people have heard me talk about plans
and they're going to want to see the
action that we take over forthcoming
months and they will see that
that wasn't known among police officers
and the fact that he also used his role
in his offending and he's not the first
how
confident are you that you can make it
but people aren't going to weaponize the
uniform as music for offended
they're a systemic there are systemic
failings in this case we had
opportunities where where warning signs
were seen by the Met
reports allegations
and we didn't follow through on those
and that's why he was still a police
officer when he shouldn't have been so
we have to repair those systemic
failings that's about leadership that's
about culture that's about standards all
things that we're going to deal with
as I said I understand that people's
confidence will be shaken but I
absolutely promise that we will rebuild
it we are determined to do that both
myself and the tens of thousands of good
men and women who are equally horrified
about these ghastly offenses
you've apologized you said it's very
upsetting do you sense these issues are
unique within the Metropolitan Police
you've LED other police forces are they
achieve constables saying they have
similar issues and indeed is it time for
a complete Rebrand of the Metropolitan
Police image
so I I think this is an issue
sadly misogyny is an issue across
Society
um policing needs to be the best because
we enforce the law we have no excuse
other than having the best standards and
we've clearly failed in this regard I
know there are other Chief constables
out there who are uh who are grabbing
hold on the same issue and confronting
similar problems in their forces I'm not
sure everyone's grabbed it yet but I
know many colleagues are doing that as
indeed other institutions are facing up
to it so there's a lot to do but as I
say I can just repeat my determination
to londoners that you will see results
as we take on those who have undermined
the bond of trust between
the police of London and our communities
and as we strengthen our community
policing as we deal better with violence
against women and girls you will see a
change that rebuilds that shake and
Trust